buongiorno oggi vorrei raccontarvi una
storia è una storia molto personale e
come tutte le storie è un mix di
avventura di gioie e di dolori
di emozioni e di amore in particolare la
storia di glancey a grace una start up
che ho avviato con due amici un altro
italiano alberto 3t un canadese cabrio
di crisi e che abbiamo avviato nel 2010
a partendo da un'idea e da un problema
di cui ci eravamo innamorati e che ha in
due anni abbiamo trasformato da un'idea
a un prodotto che poi è stato comprato
da facebook dove oggi lavoro vi confesso
che
sono un po imbarazzato perché non ho mai
raccontato la storia in questo format
l'ho raccontata spesso a come
chiacchierata e mi fa un po strano
essere qui e parlarvi della mia
avventura ma mi auguro che
possa essere uno spunto di riflessione
un ispirazione anche per voi per pensare
ai problemi che incontrate ogni giorno e
magari per darvi lo spunto di anche voi
avviare una start up o magari a di
lavorare un'idea che possa cambiare il
mondo e con questo inizierò il
l'avventura inizia nel 2006 ea nel 2006
io vivevo a milano e mi ero trasferito
da verona e ho deciso di partecipare un
programma di scambio con
universe avellino e in chicago e quindi
a senza essere mai stato negli stati
uniti prima mi trasferisco chicago e
arrivo in un mondo molto diverso da
quello a cui ero abituato è un paese
dove non conosco nessuno è un po alla
volta ho iniziato a incontrare persone
in università a in palestra ai bar e
sarà capitato anche a voi conoscere
persone nuove e molto difficile
c'è questa mancanza di di chemistry
di capacità di comunicare in maniera
genuina e spesso e volentieri il
processo è proprio dolorose un po un
processo di tra elena error provi una
volta due volte fino a quando finalmente
conosci qualcuno che
scopri ha qualcosa in comune con te
magari un vecchio amico magari il fatto
che avete studiato nella stessa
università o chiamate lo stesso autore e
quando scopre una persona che ha
qualcosa in comune con te
la dinamica della conversazione cambia
completamente la conversazione molto più
fluida
tu sei più genuino con l'altra persona
all'altra persona più aperta con te e
queste queste situazioni non succedono
spesso ma quando succedono sono
bellissime dopo chicago mi sono
trasferito a boston dopo boston a santa
fe dopo santa fe a new york ed ogni
volta ho vissuto lo stesso tipo di
problema e le stesse emozioni è un po
alla volta mi sono innamorato di questo
problema e ho sviluppato una sensibilità
diversa a questo tipo di interazioni mi
sono reso conto che in realtà avere
qualcosa in comune con un'altra persona
non è poi così difficile però è
difficile scoprirlo e ho cominciato a
pensare se ci fosse un modo per
rivelare queste connessioni che
condividiamo gli uni con gli altri per
rendere più facile conoscere persone
nuove in qualsiasi ambito un evento come
questo in un bar quando ti trasferisci
in una nuova città così nel 2010 con un
mio amico di nuovo alberto e con gabriel
che avevo conosciuto dalle menti
iniziamo a lavorare a una start up ma
all'epoca non pensavamo a glance i come
una start up in realtà stavamo lavorando
un problema che ci stava a cuore un
problema che avevamo vissuto in prima
persona e che volevamo risolvere e
c'eravamo dati all'inizio come obiettivo
di costruire una app per iphone e
android
che potesse risolvere questo problema e
ci eravamo dati un obiettivo di tre mesi
poi provarlo a vedere come andava e e
poi da lì si vedrà
in realtà dopo tre mesi siamo ancora in
alto mare
non sappiamo bene cosa stiamo facendo
stiamo imparando lungo il percorso e
anche se proviamo a contattare persone
che ci potessero aiutare riceviamo poco
riscontro decidiamo di andare avanti
anche se come studenti avevamo pochi
soldi e continuiamo a lavorare alla
stessa idea due persone si uniscono a
noi e finiamo vivere tutti insieme in
una casa che era aveva due stanze da
letto e un salotto molto piccolo ci
vediamo in cinque
lavoriamo mangiamo dormiamo lavoriamo
insieme e riprendiamo il ciclo ogni
giorno io alberto spesso e volentieri ma
c'erano questo pentolone di pasta con
questo sugo americano quindi terribile e
insomma si mangiavano insieme poi si
lavorava si esplorava questo problema se
cercava di trovare una bella soluzione
passano altri tre mesi siamo ancora in
alto mare ne passano altri tre alla fine
arriviamo ad essere un anno dalla
partenza senza soldi di nuovo senza
contatti e senza persone che ci
potessero aiutare a portare questo
prodotto il livello successivo tra
virgolette e decidiamo di lanciarlo come
possiamo quindi a un giorno apriamo tra
virgolette delle porte e la up diventa
disponibile su app store e su google
play store e all'inizio abbiamo un po di
iscrizioni ci sentiamo molto emozionati
siamo felici di vedere gente da tutto il
mondo che si iscrive ma presa ci
rendiamo conto che non sono abbastanza
per creare una vera comunità per perché
ci sia abbastanza densità di persone per
scoprire qualcuno vicino a te che vale
la pena conoscere e decidiamo allora di
tentare il tutto per tutto ed a chicago
decidiamo di trasferirci a san francisco
siamo convinti che san francisco sia una
città che capisce di più questo tipo di
idee e che ci possa dare nuove
opportunità nuovi nuovi contatti agli
alberto prendiamo una macchina e
portiamo i nostri computer e le poche
cose che avevamo e ci trasferiamo in
macchina da chicago a san francisco
siccome non avevamo soldi per l'albergo
finché uno guidava l'altra dormiva nel
posto del passeggero e viceversa e
arriviamo san francisco e per
risparmiare sull'affitto troviamo questa
famiglia etiope che aveva programmato di
viaggiare per quattro mesi e cercava un
out sister qualcuno che si prendesse
cura della casa per cui col team ci
trasferiamo in questa casa e iniziamo a
vivere lì io sono più alto quindi mi
sono piazzato nella stanza dei genitori
medio co founder sono finiti nelle
stanzine delle ragazzine che avevano
delle tende rosa avevano il cassettone
con le etichette su cosa andava in ogni
cassetto i calzini le magliette e aveva
giocattoli ovunque
era una situazione un po surreale in
realtà però creava anche leggerezza in
un momento molto difficile pensate
appunto che arriviamo a san francisco
una città molto competitiva e abbiamo
quattro mesi per cambiare completamente
la nostra situazione alla fine di quei
quattro mesi li la famiglia ritorna noi
non abbiamo un posto dove vivere e se
non riusciamo a trovare soldi prima di
quel momento dobbiamo tornare a casa ci
mettiamo al lavoro il i ragazzi
continuano a lavorare al prodotto a
cercare di migliorarlo inizio parlare a
cercare ad eventi di parlare con persone
che ci possano aiutare investor
giornalisti è un po alla volta mi faccio
strada riesco a entrare in contatto con
qualcuno per altre persone poi un'altra
persona nell'arco di tre mesi
parlo con 40 50 investor e tutti dicono
di no uno dopo l'altro uno ogni due
giorni in tutti dicono di no la nostra
idea un po perché non avevamo abbastanza
utenti un po perché eravamo stranieri un
po perché non erano sicuri in realtà non
dicevano di no dicevano forse che il
loro modo di dire di no perché non
vogliono completamente perdere il
contatto nel caso che le cose cambino ma
la verità è che ci ritroviamo al
dicembre con una bellissima e ma senza
utenti senza soldi senza investitori
senza aiuti i contatti e dobbiamo
decidere cosa fare
molte persone credo a questo punto
avrebbero deciso di tornare a casa di
provare a fare qualcosa di diverso alla
fine ce l'avevamo davvero messo tutta
però qualcosa ci diceva che il problema
che stavamo cercando di risolvere era
davvero importante
e allora abbiamo deciso di continuare a
quel punto i due ragazzi che non erano
fondatori se ne sono andati ma intra co
founder io alberto gabrio abbiamo deciso
di restare alberto gabriel si è ri
trasferiscono a chicago per vivere con
le loro ragazze perché non avevano un
posto dove stare e ha deciso di rimanere
a san francisco come avamposto ma non mi
posso permettere un affitto e allora
chiedono amico se posso vivere a casa
sua e mi trasferisco nello studio a
buccino non è una battuta non è un modo
di dire mi trasferisco letteralmente
nessuno sgabuzzino nel sottoscala
quindi in realtà aveva anche il soffitto
che andavano in giù era largo abbastanza
da infilarci un materasso e basta e
compro materassi su craigslist per 20
dollari lo baratto 10 mi piazzo lì e ho
vissuto lì per cinque mesi del resto
della storia che vi racconterò adesso
l'ho vissuta nello sgabuzzino
a gennaio quindi dopo appunto dopo
esserci trasferiti io continuo a cercare
contatti continua a lavorare per cercare
di cambiare le cose ma nel frattempo ai
miei co founder ha cominciato a
spaventarsi ad avere paura le ragazze
gli suggeriscono di trovarsi un lavoro
vero e io da san francisco gli dico
questo è il vostro vero lavoro questo è
una passione un problema che voi avete
capito importante risolvere questo è
quello che dobbiamo fare e ci fissiamo
come obiettivo un articolo sulla stampa
solo uno se poi quello non ci porta
niente allora ce ne andiamo e questa era
l'ultima nostra speranza è anche questo
ci viene tolta a fine gennaio quando
un'altra startup americana ben
finanziata con più di un milione di
dollari gli investimenti lanci un
prodotto molto simile al nostro e riceve
un articolo se tech crunch poi un altro
poi un altro e noi non sappiamo più cosa
fare non abbiamo più un punto di
riferimento e forse per disperazione
forse perché appunto non avevo più
non sapevo più cosa fare ha deciso di
scrivere un commento molto personale
molto acceso a uno di questi articoli in
cui denuncia il fatto che questo
articolo gli articoli erano stati
pubblicati parlavano solo di una start
up ma in realtà ce n'erano molte altre
di molti imprenditori tutti appassionati
di questo problema che lo volevano
risolvere e non venivano menzionati era
importante secondo me poter parlare di
tutte le tutele starter tutti i prodotti
che erano stati costruiti questo
articolo questo commento diventa viral
perché probabilmente tante altre persone
si sono immedesimate gli altri founder i
loro amici i nostri utenti e tutto ad un
tratto diventa il commento più in alto
dell'articolo è
l'autore dell'articolo l'editor di tech
crunch
quindi ne prende nota va sul nostro sito
e si rende conto che abbiamo un
bellissimo prodotto lo provano usa
conosce persone attraverso il prodotto e
decide di scrivere un articolo
tutto questo è pazzesco se ci pensate
scrivere sul blog di uno dei sul blog
più potente di silicon valley e
attaccare pubblicamente un autore e poi
avere l'autore che parla di te che prova
la tua stanza page a qualcosa di
incredibile ma in aggiunta a questo
tutto questo succede a tra febbraio e
marzo ea marzo c'è questa conferenza che
forse alcuni di voi conosceranno south
by southwest questa conferenza è dove
hanno lanciato twitter foursquare
gowalla e tante altre startup di
successo e quindi ogni anno c'è questa
sorta di aspettativa per scoprire quale
sarà the next big thing la prossima
start up di successo e così l'autore e
altri e altri blog cominciano a parlare
dell'altra start up by light e di noi
come i due candidati per appunto questo
questo the next big thing è tutto ad un
tratto quello stesso prodotto
fondamentalmente che avevamo cercato di
lanciare da 6 8 mesi
iniziamo a ricevere l'attenzione della
stampa prima tech crunch poi new york
times vostri giorni a washington post
forbes addirittura time magazine scrive
un articolo su questo spazio socio
discovery la possibilità di conoscere le
persone intorno a te utilizzando uno
smartphone e facebook e propone glessi
come uno dei prodotti migliori per farlo
io ancora viveva nello sgabuzzino e
cominciò a ricevere telefonate
dall'economist dal new york times con
giornalisti che vogliono venire a
visitare i nostri uffici e io non solo
non aveva un ufficio non aveva nemmeno
un posto dove vivere e allora ogni volta
mi inventavo una storia dicevo che ero
impegnato che ci potevamo trovare in un
coffee shop per strada tra un meeting è
un altro gli organizzatori di south by
southwest mi invitano per andare a
parlare del nostro prodotto di questo
spazio e non ho i soldi per pagarmi il
volo per pagarmi l'hotel è il volo
chiede i soldi in prestito da un amico e
per l'hotel contatto una persona
attraverso la nostra attraverso gline si
è un imprenditore che avevo conosciuto a
san francisco e che viveva ad austin e
gli chiedo se posso stare da lui il mio
e mi dice subito di sì e finisco vivere
nella stanza di sua figlia che anche lei
aveva 12 anni questo è un po e la figlia
poverina finisce a dormire sul divano e
sto ad austin e vivo questa questa
situazione incredibile questo turbinio
di emozioni
metà degli investor che avevano detto di
no inizialmente ci ricontattano sono
pronti a investire soldi persone che non
avevamo mai sentito nominare ci scrivono
dicendo che aveva centomila dollari
pronti da darci che ci potevamo mettere
d'accordo sui dettagli più tardi allo
stesso tempo ci contattano delle aziende
ci contatta facebook ci contatta google
ci contatta foursquare ed altre piccole
startup che vogliono capire che cosa
stiamo facendo e che sono curiose un po
del nostro prodotto del nostro team è un
po della tecnologia che avevamo
sviluppato purtroppo per mancanza di
tempo non posso spiegarvi dettagli ma
alberto ed io sono orgoglioso perché
siamo entrambi veneti e gabriel avevamo
sviluppato delle idee molto molto
interessanti che erano decisamente più
sofisticate delle altre app che erano
sul mercato ad ogni modo abbiamo la
possibilità di continuare a crescere
considerate che in qua in quel momento
avevano più di mille utenti al giorno
che si stavano scrivendo da poche decine
al massimo prima e oppure possiamo
unirci o una grande azienda e per
prendere questa decisione abbiamo
riguardato proprio a come avevamo scelto
di proseguire nel passato e cioè a come
risolvere il problema ci siamo chiesti
qual è il modo di risolvere il problema
perché alla fine era quello che volevamo
fare non era fare un business per il
gusto di fare business e ci siamo resi
conto che effettivamente di tutte le
opportunità che avevamo unirci a
facebook erano probabilmente il modo
migliore per effettivamente portare le
persone insieme per aiutarla connettersi
l'una con l'altra
quindi mi sono incontrato con mark
zuckeberg e abbiamo avuto la famosa
camminata dove a mi ha chiesto quello
era il nostro obiettivo quella era la
nostra missione e lui ha parlato della
loro e quel momento è stato un po come
quando vai a cena per la prima volta con
qualcuno e ti rendi conto che c'è subito
sintonia quindi siamo stati molto felici
di prendere la decisione di unirci e
facebook ed elia che sto lavorando ora
da due anni ha purtroppo non vi posso
raccontare quello che è successo dopo
per adesso però voglio concludere con un
pensiero alcuni di voi si staranno
chiedendo come mai il titolo di questo
intervento è in oro roots e tra l'altro
la mia ragazza che tedesca mi ha fatto
notare che non c'è bisogno di raccontare
a un pubblico italiano di ignorare le
regole lo facciamo già di nostro
però
l'idea è questa dopo dopo appunto questa
avventura
ho cercato di riflettere su quello che
ci era successo e di capire che cos'è
che avevamo fatto bene che cos'è che
avevamo sbagliato di di trovare delle
regole che mi potessero aiutare in
futuro che potessero aiutare altre
persone a fare quello che avevamo fatto
noi e per quanto ci provassi non
riuscivo a trovare qualcosa che
effettivamente potessi dire questa è una
regola da seguire e questa è una cosa da
non fare ma allora mi sono chiesto come
abbiamo fatto a trovare il coraggio la
forza di fare quello che abbiamo fatto
di continuare nonostante gli ostacoli e
mi sono reso conto che ci sono altre
situazioni nella vita quando facciamo la
stessa cosa e da quando siamo innamorati
quindi mi sono reso conto che la nostra
forza non era nel seguire certe regole
nel seguire un certo business model mera
di ignorare le regole e di seguire il
nostro la nostra passione ci siamo
innamorati di un problema abbiamo deciso
di risolverlo per cui mi auguro che con
questo con questa storia anche voi
possiate trovare presto un problema di
cui innamorarvi e di cambiare il mondo
risolvendolo grazie